well donut i'm not surprised about that
but on the other hand i know the
enthusiasm there is in government
to use this tournament to
as a as having a number of test events
and the idea has always been to increase
capacity
gradually it's 22 000 tonight
as it has been for the scotland game and
the croatia game
it's going to increase for the next
games here at wembley
and of course to have three quarters of
the stadium full
for the semi-finals and final will be a
great boost
is are there concerns of course there
are this argument about
our football is football being treated
as a special case
of course it is and there's no there can
be no argument about that but football
and sport has been a special case
throughout
much of this pandemic in many parts of
europe
and that is exactly what is happening
and continuing to happen
today and it's other parts of europe
they kind of up the ante wasn't it as
well in
in that uh the italians said well listen
we'll host the
the final rather than as they put it um
in a country where cases are going up
and of course we know that the
hungarians have offered to host it as
well and we've all seen their full
stadiums
hey dermot you've heard of something
called politics
and now you're hearing about something
called football politics and er
that's what this is all about but the
reality has been
that london and wembley were were
scheduled to host the semifinals in the
final because
of the confidence that uefa does have
in the state staging of matches here and
my belief is it's the last thing they
want to do
to move matches from wembley and from
london
now david you're obviously going to see
the match tonight we might talk about
the result in a minute or two but of
course you're not going to see
ben chilwell or mason mount on the pitch
what do you think about the
self-isolation you know
gary neville gary lineker have both said
well
you know they should have just been
tested instead of made to
self-isolate well it's very harsh on two
young english players
but the reality is these protocols do
exist
these bubbles for different teams have
existed
and the risks have been there and the
english fa has applied them
now should those players have been told
not to mix
in the tunnel on friday night after the
game
perhaps they should have been for sure
they should have been
but these things happen and we have to
live with them
but i mean some fans will find it a bit
strange in that so there are do it on
the pitch
you know there i remember when they
bought football back originally last
year
there were recommendations that players
shouldn't celebrate goals and things
like that
that's all lost in the wind we see the
normal
hugging and close proximity and maybe
the odd exchange of
vapors and fluids going on there you
know what is the difference between
just off the pitch and on the pitch well
firstly you're in the open air that's
the first thing that is different
but as i said right at the start of this
conversation
to pretend that football is not and
sport is not getting
special treatment is blatantly
wrong but the pleasure that is being
given
to millions of people all over europe
and beyond by this football tournament
is very real
and these things are bound to happen
when when i had the
dubious distinction of 13 years within
english football we used to have risk
assessments all the time
what if this happened what if that
happened and we concentrated
sadly in those days on safety and
security in
in one sense because that's that they
were our big fears
now this awful thing coved has come
hanging over everybody and i i'm my i'm
virtually certain that the english fa
and indeed the other fas
will have considered how they handle the
situation
it's difficult but that's football and
that's tournament football
quick thought about scotland do you
think they can do without billy gilmore
croatia i mean there may be world cup
finalists last time round and if not
england out in the semi-finals but they
they don't look that good
well scotland have a real chance there's
no doubt about that and they're not easy
to beat as
as england found out um
i would suspect that croatia are
favorites
but i as a brit will want the scots to
win and
will want the scots to progress in the
tournament
and it won't be for want of trying i
mean they
they they they have a terrific
atmosphere
even in a 25 full hamden
i suspect the noise will be deafening
and it'll be difficult for a croatian
team
who many football people believe
are past their best